how's it going everybody it's Warren the
Russo brothers are at it again
doing what they do best which is keeping
us in the dark about the Avengers in
just two days on March 21st we will get
the release of The Avengers in-game
empire magazine issue inside of it will
contain many interviews and hopefully
some more information about Avengers in
game however although it's not out some
of these interviews have come to surface
including one with the Russo brothers in
which they talk about fake Avengers in
game trailer scenes this is something
that I've done a few videos on in the
past they have admitted to doing this
for Avengers infinity war obviously the
biggest scene being the Hulk running
with the Avengers in Wakanda along with
some other scenes of course this is all
for a good purpose when they were
talking about this in their interview
with Empire magazine they talked about
how important it was to them that they
keep the film's marketing department
from spoiling the surprises when talking
about this and the interview with Empire
magazine Joe Russo said we talked about
all scales of marketing the thing that's
most important to us is that we preserve
the surprise of the narrative when I was
a kid and I saw the Empire Strikes Back
at 11:00 a.m. on the day it opened it so
profoundly moved me because I didn't
know a dang thing about the story I was
going to watch we're trying to replicate
that experience so of course to the
Russo brothers it's all about having the
movie experience be the best and not the
trailers and when previously asked about
scenes appearing in the trailers that
don't actually appear in the movie Joe
Russo said that we use all the material
that we have at our disposal to create a
trailer we look at the trailer as a very
different experience than the movie and
I think audiences are so predictive now
that you have to be very smart about how
you craft a trailer because an audience
can watch a trailer and basically tell
you what's gonna happen in the film he
goes on to say that we consume too much
content so at our disposal are lots of
different shots that aren't in the movie
that we can manipulate through CG to
tell a story that we want to tell
specifically for the purpose of the
trailer and not for the film so
basically what the Russo brothers are
saying is that they don't want the
trailers ruining the films and when
they're editing the film they cut out
some scenes that don't appear in the
movie so that's what Joe Russo is
talking about when he says we have this
extra footage that doesn't appear in the
movie so what Joe Russo is saying
is that they have all these extra scenes
left over and they manipulate them using
CGI meaning they add some things to the
scenes or they take some things out and
then they take this scene and they put
it in the trailer again a perfect
example of this is the Avengers running
through Wakanda with the Hulk there was
never actually a scene in Avengers
infinity war with the Avengers running
together like this in a wooded area in
Wakanda but they clearly filmed it but
decided to not put it into the movie so
they took this scene which was cut out
that would not appear in the movie and
they added the Hulk in it using CGI and
they put it in the trailer and in this
interview with Empire magazine Joe Russo
explains that the reason they do this is
because they want to preserve the
surprise of the narrative the movie
experience for us is so important to
them that they manipulate these trailers
so we don't know what's actually going
on now having said that all of the
footage that we see in the trailers are
not fake in fact a good majority of the
footage that we see in these trailers
are most likely real but according to
the Russo brothers we can expect a few
scenes in these trailers to not appear
in the movie again this is something
that we've all expected for some time
now and it seems like the Russo brothers
are being a little bit more open about
it now I personally love that they do
this I love going to the movies and
being surprised but let me know what you
all think about this and let me know
which scenes in the trailer you think
will not end up in the movie let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
and a reminder about my giveaway giving
away five imax tickets if you'd like to
interfere your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain I'll be picking a
winner at the end of the month as always
thank you all so much for watching will
fluff
[Music]